what's up [ __ ] my name's Ryan
right let's be crazy we're gonna be
checking out this video from Alex Luthor
Lex Luthor's brother ha that he's never
done in that joke before what this guy
does he does the thing called epic fan
made trailers okay
they live up to that title because what
he does this is one [ __ ] dude like
gets I think it's one guy like there's
like Star Wars versus Star Trek I'll go
take a collection of footage from games
shows movies and turn it into a trailer
with a different plot to it what so he
creates a whole plot just with footage
and it's with really good editing okay
okay
some videos you're like okay I could see
the editing but sometimes it's so
flawless it's like it looks like it's
one real movie yeah so this one's Batman
versus Iron Man
compassion as a witness your enemies
will not hear the small part of the
world need something more consul than
any of us everyone creates the thing
they thread
we trusted
this is why we fight in the protocol
destroyed
turn
wow-whee big
in an awesome
this looks so real so trippy
and they show you something
change this is just the beginning
I'm working on something big I came to
talk it
ah that was cool this needs to be a
thing
Wow please tell me the mic was on I'm
always a paranoid little [ __ ] okay
back to that yeah I say this every video
he manages to like in a way just crush
me because he gives you such false hope
wow this looks like it's really
happening but I like with his trailers
is if this was an actual movie this is
one spoiler filled trailer but we're not
gonna get the actual movie so he does
like a spoiler filled trailer like he
gives you sequences of Batman and Iron
Man fighting each other he gives you the
sequences of we got a team-up now when
we work together and then he shows you
that too like it's really cool how he
takes all this footage you know there's
some like special effects I gotta throw
in there every once in a while but for
the most part it's just footage wonder
though if you guys know editing at all
like that is a masterpiece
yeah like it's hard to do something like
that and it takes skill ambition and a
lot of freaking time and effort and
skill to be able to do something like
this and to make it that good and what's
so much footage you gotta like know
exactly which clip out of the hours of
footage is going to come next
yeah that is it's varied it's it it's
difficult enough alone to put together a
trailer imagine like going I gotta take
a whole bunch of [ __ ] and try to make
this into a train well he must have a
whole like storyboard process that he
has to go through to be able to make
something like this cuz I mean it's like
a film within itself Wow ya know it's
pretty [ __ ] intense it's amazing
stuff I'm just I'm so disappointed it's
not like the real thing that's gonna
happen cuz if it was I'd be one of the
first people in line I'm sure you'd be
the first one but this should happen no
they all should happen I want to make a
petition that all of Alex Luther's films
get maybe Star Wars versus Star Trek
Marvel vs. DC Star Wars versus Marvel DC
Superman versus Hulk all that Deadpool
vs. Batman they all [ __ ] Rock Joe
and binge watch all this [ __ ]
trailers now anyway guys if any the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects and alissa be crazy has a
channel to a lot of fun [ __ ] on that
channel check it you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter where
Alissa tweets pictures of her boobs
what about [ __ ] fix Oh simplicity said
[ __ ]
cuz I'm bold but I can't look at you in
the eyes right now it's not enough for
both